Now that we have our landscape sculpted, let's take a look at how we can paint the landscape.
Now before we can start painting the landscape, what we're going to need to do first is create a material
that uses a node called the Landscape Layer Blend.
And the Landscape Layer Blend allows us to basically do that blend between these various layers.
Now for this example, we're going to be creating it using just some colors.
We're going to make a dirt, a rock, and a grass.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor now.
Now if you are in the Landscape Tools, you should come out of them by coming up to the selection mode here
and just going into selection to get out of the tools if you're in them.
We're going to hit Control Space on the keyboard, come to our content, and then right click and make a material.
We're going to call this new material M-A-T underscore Landscape.
And then once we have created it, we're going to double click on it to open it up.
Just bring this over here.
Now what we're going to do first is we're going to look for our Landscape Layer Blend.
So to do that, we're going to right click in the graph of the material and look for our Landscape.
And right there we have our Landscape Layer Blend.
Now by default, there are actually no inputs for this node.
So to add some, what we need to do is make sure we have the node selected.
And then in the Details panel under Layers, we need to add three elements.
You can see that as soon as I do that, I get a Layer None, Layer None, and Layer None.
Now for this example, we are going to have a dirt, a rock, and a grass.
So each one of these indexes, layers, names is going to be named like this.
And you can see here I have my layer dirt, my layer rock, and my layer grass.
So next what we're going to do is we're going to right click and we're going to look for a vector.
And we want a vector parameter.
So just type in vector and then PA and there's a vector parameter.
We're going to call this first one dirt.
And I'm going to give it a default color of some kind of like a dirtish looking something.
So maybe something a little bit like that.
Okay, we're going to plug this in to our dirt.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to right click on this and duplicate it.
And then we're going to call this New One Rock.
And then we're going to give it a new color, kind of like a grayish color.
We'll go a little bit of a darker gray, a little bit too dark.
All right, and then we're going to plug this into our rock.
And then we're going to right click and duplicate again.
And we're going to call this one grass.
I'm going to give this some type of darkish kind of grassy looking color.
There we go.
And then we're going to plug this right here.
Now, once that is completed, we need to take the output from our landscape layer blend
and bring that right into this base color.
And then let's just compile and save our material.
Because the next thing that we're going to do here is once we've done this part,
we're now going to do this part, which is going to add a normal to this.
This is going to make it a little bit easier to see the differences between them.
And it's just going to give a little bit more life to our material.
So let's go back over here to our material.
And this is actually really cool.
What we can do now is we can right click on this and duplicate it and bring it down here.
And we're just going to plug this right into our normal.
And then what we're going to do is don't mind that.
That'll be taken care of in just a second.
We're going to make some parameters to control the size of our textures.
So we're going to left click and look for something called a landscape.
And we're going to look for this landscape layer coordinates.
There we go.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to look for a constant.
And for this constant, we're going to give it a value of one.
But we also want to make this adjustable inside of the material instance.
So we're going to right click on it and convert it to a parameter.
And then we're going to call this normal tile.
Then what we need to do next is we need to multiply these two together.
So we're going to drag off of this and look for a mole and under our math multiply.
We're going to add that.
And then we're going to take the output of our normal tile and plug that right into our multiply there.
Now with the tiling logic set up, the next thing that we need to do is create our normal map.
So to do this, there's a couple of different ways.
One of the ways that we can add a normal map is by just holding down the t key and clicking.
And that's going to add a texture sample.
So again, I just did that by holding down the t key on the keyboard and left clicked.
Then we're going to right click on this and convert it to a parameter.
And we're going to call this n underscore dirt.
And we're going to do a couple of things now.
We are going to take the multiply and plug that into our UV.
And then on the n underscore dirt, we're also going to need to give it a default texture.
So we're going to look for something here.
I'm just going to look for dirt.
We'll just do an underscore n and then we will give it something like, I don't know, this rocky something looks pretty good.
Okay.
So the next thing that we need to do is we need another one of these for our rock and our grass.
So this is actually going to be really quick because we already have most of this set up.
So all we need to do is right click, duplicate and then instead of calling this n dirt, we're going to call this n underscore rock.
We're going to plug the multiply in to our UV right there.
And then if we want, we can change this.
We'll just do underscore in to look for again some normal maps and we'll do maybe some ground gravel.
There we go.
And then right click, duplicate, pull this down.
I'm going to call it n underscore graph.
And then like we did before, we're going to bring the multiply down into the UVs and then we're going to look for something.
We actually have a ground moss.
There we go.
That'll work for us for the time being.
And then what we need to do is we need to plug these into the respective inputs on the landscape layer blend.
All right, so let's just apply and save.
So we are done with that, but there's a couple of things that we need to do next.
So what we're going to do is we need to select our landscape and apply this material, but we're not going to apply the material itself.
What we're going to do is we're going to make an instance of that material and the instance is going to make it easier for us to adjust.
So we're going to come back over here.
I'm going to close.
Oops, said back over here.
We're going to close this down.
I'm going to hit control space.
On our material landscape, I'm going to right click and go create material instance.
All right, so that's going to create our landscape material instance.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to select our landscape.
Make sure our material instance is selected in the content browser here and over in the details panel, we're going to look for our material, which if we come down here, it's going to be under our landscape and then our landscape material.
And we're going to say use selected asset from the content browser.
And this is going to take just a second.
There we go.
And we're not seeing anything.
And that's because we need to assign something called weight blended layers to each one of our layers for our landscape.
And what these are going to act as is a mask so that when we go to paint, we can expose the dirt or the rock or the grass.
So let's take a look at how we do that right now.
So we're going to come over here to our selection mode and go down to landscape.
And then we're going to make sure we're on the paint tool.
And you can see here there are no current layers assigned.
So what we want to do so that we're on default, and then we're going to hit the create layers from assigned materials.
And that's going to create our different layers here.
All right.
And then what we need to do is we're going to come right here to the layer info and we're going to go where weight blended layer normal.
It's going to ask us where we want to save this and we're going to save it to the untitled three, which is just going to take this math name and put it in the folder.
So we're going to save there.
There we go.
And then we're going to do the same thing for our rock.
We're going to do the same thing again.
There we go.
And then we're going to do the same thing for our grass.
Now there are a few options that we have that are kind of under the hood, so to speak.
And if you right click on the layers, you're going to get the ability to export or import, but you also have this fill clear and rebuild material so that fill is going to fill any particular layer with like doing a fill in Photoshop.
You'll fill it with your dirt or your rock or your grass.
The clear layer is going to do the opposite.
If you right click on this and clear it, it will get rid of the dirt, the rock or the grass and the rebuild materials is used.
And if you happen to change your material drastically and you want to rebuild the material is used behind the scenes, then you will use that to do that.
Now, all that's left to do is to paint.
Now there's actually two things that we can do.
We can paint and we can smooth and basically paint will allow us to paint our various areas and then smooth will allow us to smooth the transition between those two.
And by doing that, we can get something that looks like this.
So again, let's pop over to the editor now and I'm going to come over here to my rock and let's say that, you know, I want to just come over here and start painting some rock.
So there we go.
So the rock selected brush probably a little bit smaller than that.
There's that rock that I have added there.
And then I can do the same thing with my grass.
So there we go.
And then if I want to, I can come here and I can smooth out kind of in between them.
You can also use the bracket keys on your keyboard.
Left bracket will make things smaller and the right bracket will make things, your brush bigger so that you can get a better smoothing and things like that.
I'm going to hit control space because I also want to come over here and mention one thing about the landscape material instance.
So if I was to bring this out and do something like, you know, normal tile, maybe we set this like 0.1.
You can see here, we're going to get a little bit of some better looking kind of tiling information on that.
And then also we could do something like come here, maybe our grass is a little, little too green for my, my liking.
So we're going to maybe not make it black, but bring it back over here.
There we go.
That's a little bit better.
It's a little too bright.
There we go.
That looks, that looks a way better for grass right there.
So if I come here and go to paint, get some little bit better looking grass.
So again, that's why we want to use this material instance because it makes it really easy for us to be able to adjust things as we are going on the fly.
So what I want everybody to do now is take some time to paint their landscape and make adjustments.
And when we come back, we will take a look at how we can apply mesh based foliage to our landscape to make the landscape look even more lush and full of life.
Thank you.